hi everyone I'm going to talk about my
work on exchange network dynamics today
and it will be about pretty much like
trying to understand some complex system
where the data is not enough to tell a
story so you have to fill in the gaps
with your knowledge first I want to give
you a little bit of context and
introductions imc is a trading company
in Amsterdam like based in Amsterdam
with offices in Chicago and Sydney as
well and I work as a performance analyst
in there and here performance means the
performance of networks and systems so
we heavily value automation and like
most of our trading is not done by
people but by actual but by auto traders
which are hosted on servers and for that
stick the performance is an integral
part of it and yeah finally we are yeah
I mean you you might have seen our dues
already and you're hiring so if you are
interested in like living in one of
these three cities feel free to check
out the careers section first I want to
give you how this automated trading
works in a very high level the the way
we start with is first you have a signal
that you may want to react on so this
signal can be like any piece of
knowledge it could be market data it
could be like some news updates
it could be Donald Trump tweet but in
here everything we just treated as a
signal and assume that our system can
parse it and make use of it so then we
have this participant
which is happens to be a machine and
then based on the signal they make
decisions to whether to send an order or
not and then the order will go through a
network it will eventually reach the
exchange so signal signal tense an order
network exchange prophet and the thing
is most of like
like when you get a signal it actually
comes with some reaction window attached
to it so suppose you get this tweet and
it has some window of like half a
millisecond of course you're not aware
of it but then you send an order and the
network appears to be busy and it takes
you a second actually reach there which
is actually ridiculous but then you will
be too late and your orders won't be
successful anymore so like and we want
to avoid that to be able to do our
business so then the question to ask is
like the first thing that comes to mind
is if I improve my reaction time a
little bit would it actually affect my
chances would I be able to do better and
the other question that you might want
to ask is how is this opportunity window
even like how much does this matter if
it was the other way around if I was
late all the time how much of my orders
would end up being successful so like
that's the type of questions that we
want to answer it's not an exhaustive
list but that's like the type of
analysis we do when we are looking in to
have this network how this network works
so to do this we want to of course we
get the data and then come up with
insights but here the trouble is most of
the time the data you get will not be
enough to answer these questions either
like like either like actually the
variables you are looking for won't even
be in the data or or even if they are in
the data sometimes you can fit a model
to it but it won't have much of a power
to explain anything in those cases we
want to like still make use of the data
but add what we know about the system
into into the model so most of the time
for instance we won't know the Pats an
individual order we sent to the network
took but we will have some knowledge
about how this network is connected like
what components are there what are the
who are defenders how do they behave how
does the queueing in this network how
does this queuing network queuing
effects our orders so to do this like we
need approaches that actually allow
encoding our knowledge into the model as
well and here I'm going to talk about
two approaches that that helps you do
that and they're these approaches I
think encoding your knowledge comes
naturally so the first one is PI mc3 the
probabilistic programming language where
you encode your knowledge as
distributions and parameters and the
other one is through discrete event
simulation where if if you don't have if
you cannot represent your knowledge just
with probability distributions if you
cannot work out to matter if it's just
impossible then you can simply just code
out the behavior and then simulate it
what is not in here is like the
supervised learning because as I said
like if the data does not have enough
like does is not sufficient and just
getting the data and throw beginning to
your favorite machine learning algorithm
might not work but in the probabilistic
part there are some like in the sub
models there's some under the hood parts
of supervised learning as well in form
of linear models first here I'm going to
actually talk about PI MC with a more
high-level model and then move on to
these creative and simulations and Yap
IMC part will be a bit shorter compared
to discrete-event parts and with this
even part I'm going to show a couple
code examples as well
but first yeah IMC just like for those
that don't know it's a probabilistic
programming language you represent your
your model in terms of variables and
these variables can be three random
variables which are variables that you
sample from a distribution or they can
be observed which means it's your data
or it can be deterministic which means
it's a function of these variable other
variables in your model and below like
the at the right part is yeah some
example of a model which is not very
visible but it's like just one of the
many models that I played around with
when I when I used PMC to solve this
issue so it's like pretty much you in
the end have a graph you can see that
which variables end up generating which
variables and how do they end up with at
the data so with the high-level model it
works as follows we at this point we add
a little bit of our knowledge about the
network we know that the network is
prone to queuing so like we are we end
up queuing behind other packets in some
cases and this these cases we called
bursts so there are moments that are
busy in the network and if we get caught
in a burst we end up doing so then the
first thing we want to model is how
often do these bursts happen and how
often do we end up queuing when there's
a burst and then the second thing is the
thing that we can control is our own
performance which is our reaction time
so then we have an abstract variable
that generates our generates the
parameters of our reaction time
distribution so I'm not going to like go
all the way and all the details of the
model in here but the thing is in the
end
these like high-level parameters will
generate the actual model parameters
which in the end will generate observed
variables which are our success rate our
reaction time and how long did it take
to reach the matching engine and these
are actually kind of related like the
fastest fear the more successful we are
going to be and the less likely we are
going to do and since we are going to
kill less we we are going to take less
time to matching engine and this time to
matching engine is a mixture
distribution because when you two versus
when you don't you you have two
different latency characteristics and
here to fit to data I use variational
inference which worked out fine and then
we get some posterior samples so then
the first thing to do is to do some
sanity check to make sure that the model
is not completely off the track so like
you're not trying to match the
distribution and the data they are not
trying to match hundred-percent but if
the distribution is completely off then
you have to of course go back and revise
your model so it's not a perfect match
but it also doesn't sound like we look
like we have done something horribly
wrong and it can also estimate the
success rates relatively closely so then
based after this we can look into this
all the other parameters of the model
that answer some of our questions like
first it tells us again the distribution
of our reaction time but it also tells
how often we are queueing like and how
much worse are there but is our success
rate and finally if we were extremely
late late to react then how bad would
our success rate be like what's the
absolute worst worst-case scenario
yeah so this is where I'm going to stop
it by MC they're actually like more
things that I could have talked about
for instance we could have wanted to add
more detail to the model instead of just
this queueing effect success/failure we
could try to look into each and every
component that causes these latencies
and then create create an additive model
of these latencies and the second thing
we could have tried to do is this
reaction window that I mentioned that
where you are too late you no longer are
successful we could have tried to model
this more explicitly and finally one
other thing that would be nice to look
at is to comparison of Markov chain
Monte Carlo versus variational inference
and see how much our estimations change
yeah now I'm moving on to discrete event
simulation so the idea of a discrete
event simulation is that and why is all
these suites event is this is a
simulation where you have events that
have been scheduled to happen and what
it does is similar later does not
simulate each and every single time unit
but it's just fast forward to the next
event in there and then you have
processes that listen for the events and
then generate events so in case of
simple the way it works out is you first
have an environment object which pretty
much is actually your simulation and
keeps track of time and then you have
events which are single instances and
they are either not scheduled yet
scheduled to happen or they fired or
they might have failed and then your
processes which listen for these events
and generate these events and they can
be either represents physical objects
like the network switches or the
participant in the network but it they
could also
represents like actions actions that are
one-off
so the difference is processes are like
processes are generators in simple and
so if you have a like a while true loop
that never ends then it will be one of
these physical processes that are
unending whereas if you have a generator
that is finite and you will have a
one-off process that tends to represent
an action finally there are resources
and what the resources do like there
they are convenience features that help
you not come up with your own data
structures and then you can model
chewing the effects congestions waiting
for like semaphores and such such
without like explicit decoding them and
the way simple works is you use the same
interface for waiting for an event to
happen or waiting for a process to
finish or waiting for a resource to be
released so that's actually quite
convenient than you are coding this out
so now I'm going to show up the network
with a bit more detail so just opening
up and we have we have two switches on
first layer one switch between us and
the matching engine and we have multiple
participants so first thing then we can
add to this discrete event simulation is
the structure of this network
second thing is we know that our
observed variables they are latencies so
they are delayed so we can actually add
this to our model as well so within
networking there are four types of delay
you have propagation which is
essentially the time it takes for signal
to reach from one physical place to
another so it's determined by cable
length and speed of light and then you
have the processing time which is like
this which actually reads the packet and
then decides on what to do with it
and you had transmission which has the
switch writing packets to the line which
is determined by the size of the packet
and line rate like how many gigabits per
second and finally we have queuing delay
if multiple packets are going for the
same line then one has to wait for the
transmission time of the other next we
know that there are bursts in the
network and we know that these can be
multiple packets so this is something we
can take into account as well we can
simulate these bursts as some
participant groups that send out a
handful of packets and finally we have
chewing the the queuing we see in the
network normally you expect the queues
to be FIFO first in first out the thing
is this people this people property only
works out to a certain time precision if
the packets are really close to each
other and by close to each other I mean
like in terms of like like tens of
nanoseconds then you can have reordering
at at the queue as well so then you have
to add this non-deterministic effect
into the simulation to make it more
accurate yeah
first some building blocks to show you
how it works you create an environment
object as the simulation and then here
are some like these are custom classes
that contain processes in them here this
is a very simple network with two
participants Alice and Bob a single
switch and the matching engine and then
we use the run method of the environment
to run it for a duration it's mostly
like all the debugging and stuff that
are not really relevant to the slide
then here's an example of an object and
here we like this is a perfect FIFO
switch with three different processes so
the first we have method that takes
incoming packets from a queue called
incoming packets and that means like
that process will be blocked until some
packet actually come to the queue and
after that it will process these packets
wait for the processing delay and here
this process packets function it will
it's a like one time generator so it
every time every time a packet is
processed we will create a new process
just for this action and after this
process is need is complete they will go
to the output queue and then in the
queue you see in the in the loop like
the transmission will happen with one
packet at a time and then if there are
multiple packets then the other packet
will have to wait for the transmission
delay of the of the first one then we
run the simulation and we get an we can
if we are debugging it we can get some
output and we can see that's first yeah
in here everything is deterministic
nothing random so far so they they're a
periodical signals they received a
signal at the same time they react at
the same time and then they eventually
go to the switch and then we can see
that one has to beat for the
transmission delay of the other and then
eventually they reach the matching
engine so so far yeah what I showed you
was yes super deterministic and simpler
example we have to add this first non
determinism that I mentioned to the
switches to make the simulation work
then we have to add a signal generator
object that represents signals
being random and not just periodic
signals and finally we need to add a
burst objects that's that represents
multiple packets that happen to be at
the same time in the same switch as us
so I'm not going to the details of these
so I'm going to fast forward to 10 how
it would look like then we put all of
this together we first have then we
first have the exchange which is like
the structure I showed you before
then we know that instead three where
the matching engine is the root of the
tree and the participants are the leaves
of the leaves of it so we just create
objects accordingly and tell them the
destinations
next we actually put all the randomness
in the simulation in there so we have a
first we have distributions that that we
know at least we think we know like to
see distribution of the signal and the
processing delay of the switch but there
are also distributions that are
parameterize like the ones that we sort
of have a vague idea about how they work
but we don't know the exact parameters
that's what we are going to search for
so that's that's the number of reactions
on average we might X X sorry number of
like burst packets we might expect on a
switch and the distribution of our
window and and the time offset of the
reactions compared of the bursts
compared to our reaction and finally we
have our reaction time distribution it
is known it is but we still parameterize
it because after we work out the
simulation we also want to speculate
about if we change our reaction time how
things go differently so these are the
parameters that I mentioned and
the average reaction time is a parameter
that is parameterize but we fix it when
we are fitting the model and we have a
like to optimize we use energy distance
between the distribution distribution
generated by the simulation versus the
actual distribution of the data so again
a pretty close distribution of course it
doesn't capture details very well but
it's not extremely far off and after
fitting the model then we can actually
then modify our reaction time and see
that if we actually if we were 59
seconds faster how much success rate
would it correspond to so then you run
the simulation again but with different
reaction time parameters and it will be
a bit noisy depending on how long you
run the simulation in here these are
like actually only five minute chunks
but in this high frequency world like
even a second is an eternity so it's
usually enough to see what's going on so
then this tells us that yeah if fever 50
nano seconds faster than our success
rate would approach 88% yeah so then we
have two ways of dealing with this
problem where we incorporate our
knowledge into the model first we have
pi MC and then sin pi for discreet
events and then the question is like
which one to use event so in you know in
my experience with our models and the
problems we deal with it I would usually
start with PI MC and unless I then I get
the point where I cannot just
use use just distributions to model this
problem anymore
I switch to simple but in general if you
have many parameters and you want to
just create your model with fever lines
of code as possible then PI MC 3 is the
better choice in case of in case you
want to add more details to the as low
level as possible and if your physical
process has a lot of discrete variables
it means you know choices if-then-else
statements and such then and it has many
moving parts than simple is better so
like you can have a huge complexity but
few but the complexity will be about sub
parts that you know have divert and
finally with sin pi you can you can
scale it a little bit better because if
you can relax your simulation a bit if
you run for instance only 5 minute
chunks and such then you can use your
like you spice Park task whatever your
favorite cluster and then just use as
many processes as you want yeah
to summarize I showed you ways of
incorporating knowledge into your model
and I'll show you two ways of doing this
and my suggestion is yeah use the
shortest way that's possible and then go
with the more explicit and detail way if
things no longer work for you yeah
it's going to has been a bit shorter but
yeah thank you and questions
[Applause]
[Music]
yes they can indeed be correlated it's
not 100% so there are cases where
everyone wants to do the same thing at
the same time but there are also bursts
where like like because like whatever
happened previously like to so long that
there's like they are still being
processed by the network so like they
are actually unrelated events but it's
just like the previous events took too
much to process and the network still
has has the load of this so there are
both cases
[Music]
yeah that these definitely happen yes Oh
between the how bad is it yeah yeah so
we looked at this and there is indeed
like the way we look at it is eiv we
assign a cost to this trace as you said
and then we look at the success rate and
there's indeed yeah usually the higher
the costs then the higher the cost fewer
the success rate is
[Music]
yeah so yeah it's so the question is
about calibrating the data with discrete
event simulation right yeah so that's
actually like the way I did with this
was just pretty much compare
distribution generated by discrete event
simulation versus the actual
distribution but what I didn't really
talk about how to optimize this ideally
I would be using some either similar
optimization techniques in the these
bayesian methods but in this case it was
just like random search and grid search
that took care of that oh yeah
yeah actually that's something I should
have mentioned earlier so I'm glad you
asked so the idea is if I get in here
like so you have a graph like that's
like that tells you that so your success
rate improves which means usually your
profitability improves but the thing is
you think faster also has a cost
this is either cost as in you actually
pay some money or it means cost in
manpower development time or opportunity
cost on not doing working on some other
project so then the thing the more like
the business problem that you try to
answer is is it worth spending my time
on getting 50 nanoseconds hundred
nanoseconds faster or should I will be
doing something else with my time does
this answer your question unfortunately
not
yes thank our speaker again
[Applause]